[Music]
in next level car alarm news guy in a
juice drink that pops out and went every
time somebody trying to break into a car
it will work 100 I will try to break
into a car every day just a lot yeah
give I can break a window a guy just
pops out in the guise of Jesus dream
with American flag on like excuse me
this person's trying to steal your car
alarms you don't look that way but if
there was that guy you what the [ __ ] is
going on this guy's trying to steal this
guy's trying to steal I wouldn't have
gotten my catalytic converter ripped out
no my Cadillac converter submitted by
Air Force Ones
that's all shoes dumping in my Air Force
Ones do people still wear those yeah
dude
Allah [ __ ] man they still in there just
heavy as [ __ ] dude look at me hello
heavy it's like 80% of the weight is
just on the part of the liver a new
Toyota patent would let car spray
thieves with tear gas come up with it I
know right well because they were
sorting out a bunch of other [ __ ]
you know in other countries they have
torch like torches tied to their like
hooked up to their car so if they try to
break in it just goes that sounds like
some Russian [ __ ] it's Africa yeah
that's crazy that sounds expensive
so Toyota recently pet patented and anti
theft deterrent so it's titled vehicle
fragrance dispenser and so there's three
functions there's one fragrance to quote
improve the mood of the occupants
husband's are always using that ship for
the party s wives Oh [ __ ] it gets to
you is coming in here you know it
[ __ ] it Bart because as soon as they get
it it smells like [ __ ] I know I know but
I roll down the windows then the second
function would be for you a deodorizer
that will remove odors and then the
final would be a tear gas dispenser that
will activate in case and
gentlemen that's dull engine start has
been detected what if you did it on
accident and then you can't [ __ ]
spray yeah this whole system is
controlled by an automatic link to the
drivers smartphone kinda like well what
Tesla does already how you could just
walk into your car and start a lot of
cars are getting that [ __ ] though yeah a
lot of them are doing that I wonder if
after you you put this state gas on you
have to go back and drive that stick yes
car oh oh yeah yeah so then they're
saying that if you're not a registered
driver to like for this car and then you
sit in the driver's seat bills free well
I would love to cheer yes my teenage kid
they try to stick a card [ __ ] blob write
a favor yeah so you'll get gas sort of
like a whoopee cushion is it weight
isn't gonna be gas it burns or just
gonna be stinky tear gas
no it's tear gas so you'll be blinded Oh
dangerous they'll be driving yeah I was
like if it's just stinky gas that's not
gonna work cuz if I came here to steal
this car I'm gonna plug my nose up and
steal this car no I'll blind you the
point is to prevail you from again the
car moving exactly so they're saying
that they're already like BMW and
Mercedes have already installed systems
that can dispense fragrance into the
cabin using like certain pods and stuff
but this is the first time that they're
trying to use this technology like to
weaponize the car yeah hi I'm sorry
question I feel like there are better
ways to keep me from getting it like
this just sounds like somebody mediums I
dude you know would be [ __ ] sick
what's a better way I don't know I'm not
an engineer spikes coming out of the
steering wheel maybe I think what makes
this one work is they already we're
gonna add a new positive function so now
you just have to put the tear gas
cartridge in it so it's not they don't
they invent a whole new function like
Joe's idea the best which one is that
one
I think they do not was like you know
virtual be like a projection or
something - that's like we have
Holograms now that'd be dope like it's
just a hologram of that person's
grandmother coming out you were Jeffrey
how dare you I taught you better than
this you're disappointing me I see
that's what I'm saying a group of
engineers came together and they and the
best they could come up with Mystere
gasps oh no sounds dangerous what about
if it's like applied to the face and
it's like and then they can't drive any
crash and it's got poop in it oh that's
that's true we got to do it in a way
where it doesn't hurt the car cuz that's
the whole point right you want to you
want to keep the car intact you don't
want it to be - this still ahead I mean
the coming the cool thing about Tesla
you can't really steal it unless you
have the actual key fob there's no way -
[ __ ] it like you know do the wires [ __ ]
yeah so why don't we just go with that
hey well you know what um Jeremy was
telling me recently like he has a friend
that has a Tesla open the B and then
that they they break into the small
window in the backseat and then pull the
backseat down because that small window
isn't connected here that everybody but
then like they start breaking into a
whole bunch of Tesla's criminals are
smart why would you ever park your Tesla
outside you have to charge it inside the
house yeah maybe not everyone has I
don't know I'm not leaving my [ __ ]
hundred thousand dollar car out of the
street like in the garage or it could be
at a parking lot it could you know who
knows you have to charge it inside so
I'm gonna have money and housing for the
vehicle in order to have one no you
could do a charger you gotta be like
charged it though oh there's no oh
there's no street side parking you're
absolutely correct
I do see Tesla's on the street down the
street I would never cuz it's like
having a phone like you kind of need a
place that you live that has a plug like
if you want to live off the grid and
camp all the day I mean all the times
gonna be hard to have a phone what if
you can just go up and like spend time
out of your day to go and charge it you
can't have that if we do that - wait so
the Tesla won't start if you don't have
your phone on you or the key fob you
need the key fob oh ok cuz I was
thinking if you had to have your phone
one addition ID
I get in the car started up you can't do
anything I charge in the Tesla's
complicated technology scares me I give
you a little keep up just in case bro I
just printed documents using my phone I
was like [ __ ] love this what do you
mean yes I'd have thought that I
downloaded can you check your email so I
had a PDF I'm like okay I have that
whatever and then I just went print and
then I gonna just printed that [ __ ] up
oh I got you hooked up a little tiny I
thought too for a second I think what
are you talking about like into light
the little like I thought you like
plugged it into the port and had a
little tiny printer and I was like well
you can do so a tiny little paper when I
used to do sketches I always had a
printable a printable a portable printer
that's just battery powered and then we
would just print stuff on site with
paper is I always had it in my car I
doctor had that [ __ ] it's a scanner
and it's like they're just a little bar
and she goes whoop and it's scanned I'm
like how do you know you scanned it
though I miss stealing things stealing
cars is like crazy cuz you just can't
believe you stole the car happening yeah
you would steal a car before did you
guys ever used to put nails and people's
tires that pissed you off no I never did
any of that [ __ ] that's bad and by the
way I was under the age of 18 so
breaking in and all that stuff cuz like
um like the way that sparkplug pieces
react to glass is [ __ ] nuts yeah when
you throw it at you don't throw the
whole spark plug you just crack the this
little it's kind of like like a clay
material that's around the it's like a
white part right you crack that open and
it's like a little piece like this and
you toss it and in the hole glass goes
boom yeah and it turned into like
cracked spiderweb and you just push it
and it just shatters yeah that was crazy
and then I never always just when I
first saw that I was like oh my god dude
these guys are like double-oh-seven
how do you figure that out forgot what
it was it's like an old trick that
everybody knew if they're a boy if
you're a stupid boy and then I don't
know I just I think when you're young or
two you don't think of um you're more
you're a lot stupider and you don't
think that it's actually someone's
property you think it's like
a tree like it just sits it's there on
the street you just throw like [ __ ]
like salami and baloney onto a car leave
it out the sudden trip to the paint
people put eggs on cars yeah yeah I know
that was [ __ ] up that's what boys are
doing that's they're done yeah boys
aren't doing stupid I never did you know
what my friend had a big stack of bumper
stickers and first we don't know like
how this happened but we covered a whole
entire Astro van with the bumper sticker
yeah it was like a sports team and [ __ ]
it was like one of those works like this
and just like a there's like a flag
within the bumper sticker and it was
like blue maybe it was Dallas Cowboys I
forgot what it was but then um so all of
us after we did that we were walking and
then you know one of our friends was
getting covered like in his back with it
like we're throwing the sticker on his
back and then the the astral van came
and they were yeah they were [ __ ]
going crazy and my friend didn't know he
had all the stickers in his back so he
was arguing with them back like how the
[ __ ] we do [ __ ] to [ __ ] up dude he found
us because he drove up and he saw the
[ __ ] stickers all over his back No
thank God I thought we were gonna get
our asses kicked we just had to like
peel them off really slow and then he
was just saying like man this is gonna
cost me a lot of money all this stuff
and I was just like [ __ ] dude we really
let ourselves you know I don't know like
you know when you're that age and you
get too excited to do something you
forget what you're doing is wrong and
you just it's so funny no girls still
kind of did stuff like that like I think
when I was like 14 or 15 I remember
these girls invited me to hang out and
they were like yeah we're gonna go to
the mall and I showed up at this girl's
house and like she they both put their
like okay we're going to the mom my
dad's gonna take us and they had these
giant bags and I was like wow those are
some big bags maybe I shoulda brought a
bigger bag it fit in and almost like
whatever
these [ __ ] robbed these malls blind
she was just [ __ ] putting all dude in
the back
what's like this [ __ ] big and it was
like a um it was like you know there was
recyclable bag so they use now the
grocery stores it was like that texture
and like it was just this huge [ __ ]
bag and she was like this little girl
and she just had Dave they robbed how
much you want to bet she wouldn't have
gotten away with that in a Korean store
she wouldn't no absolutely not because
it was a big [ __ ] bag
my dad suspicious of everybody kids
children elderly it doesn't [ __ ]
matter dude yeah and then like and then
like I thought that I would be cool like
them and then one time I tried to steal
a pack of holes
coughs drops from the gas station I got
caught of course you know why yeah if
you want a white girl with blonde hair
there's been like that's heard obviously
I never did that [ __ ] again I was so
scared oh and take everything these
[ __ ] high clothes makeup jewelry and
dry cough drops were you I have an
assault sore throat I needed this serve
just going on a family trip and I was
upset and rebelling it did not go well I
mean you could got Oreos
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]